talk a little bit about what could cause
the supply or demand curve for a
currency to shift so here we have the
foreign exchange market for the chinese
one which is why we have the quantity of
one on the horizontal axis and the price
of one in terms of another currency on
the vertical axis and here that other
currency is the u.s dollar
and associated with let's just call this
s sub 1 our supply curve and d sub 1 our
demand curve you have at the
intersection an equilibrium point we
have talked about this in other videos
let's call that e sub 1. this would be
some dollar price for a wand maybe it's
10 u.s cents per one and then associated
with that is also an equilibrium
quantity q sub 1. that would be a
certain amount of one that is trading
hands in a certain time period whatever
the time period this this graph or this
model applies to
so one big way to think about what would
influence supply and demand is think
about who holds the supply and then who
is demanding that currency so if we
think about the market for the chinese
one the supply is going to be from
people who hold one so people
who
hold one
and for the most part that's going to be
people in the country it's possible that
someone sitting in new york has a one
denominated account or has some wand
sitting in their wallet but for the most
part it's going to be people in the
country so motivated
motivated for the most part by
what happens in china what happens
happens in china
and on the other hand if we're thinking
about demand it's the other way around
these would be other people that for
some reason want to convert their
currency their non-wan currency into the
wan
so people
who hold
other currencies
other
other currencies like the us dollars and
so this tends to be motivated it's
possible that someone in beijing is
holding dollars or has a dollar bank
account but for the most part it's going
to be motivated
motivated
by other countries
other
other countries
and so for example if we think about
supply what could shift the supply to
the right or could increase supply so
shifting to the supply means more
chinese want to sell their wand they
want to convert it into something else
let's say us dollars
and so this could be an increase in
demand
so increase in demand
for for
foreign
foreign we could say goods
services
or assets
in this case it might be an increase in
demand for american goods services or
assets they might want american assets
because they get a better return there
or maybe they view them as safer
investments maybe they want to send
their children to an american college so
there's a demand or there's an increase
in demand for sending kids to the
american colleges so that's a service
maybe they are interested in buying more
american cars another thing that could
increase the demand for say american
goods is if there's a decrease in
tariffs on those things so those things
have become cheaper in china so any of
these things could shift the supply
curve to the right this is s sub 2 and
then associated with that
we would have a new equilibrium exchange
rate e sub 2 and a new equilibrium
quantity that is changing hands and
notice the price of the juan has now
gone down as people are demanding in
this case more american goods and of
course if we switch the arrows here if
we if we had a lower demand for let's
say american goods services and assets
then the supply curve would shift to the
left and the wand would become more
expensive in terms of dollars
and so on the demand side it works the
other way around what could shift the
demand curve to the right so let's say
this is d
let's call this d3 right over here to
right over here let's assume that the
supply curve has not been shifted
so this would go to e sub three so the
one has become more expensive and that
makes sense more people are demanding it
and we have a different quantity now
let's call that q sub three but what
would cause it to shift in that way
so demand
for
one
for
one
would go up if you have an increase in
demand
for
chinese goods from foreigners chinese
goods actually i should say services
services or assets
so if you have an increase in the number
of americans who were holding dollars or
are holding dollars and saying hey i
could get a better return if i invest in
china maybe it's growing faster and so i
want to convert my dollars into one i
want to buy one with my dollars so that
i could buy so i could participate in
the chinese stock market or buy shares
and uh or somehow buy some chinese real
estate or whatever else it might be and
obviously if demand for chinese good
services and assets were to go down then
the demand curve would shift the other
way